хочу поговорити про те що є самим
важливим в нашій державі ще раз самим
важливим в нашій державі це є
Військо це є армія це є війна і от
сьогодні нас сьогодні друзі з вами
це ж у нас перший раз ми зібралися в
грудні місяці ми в грудні місяці ще не
збиралися в нас сьогодні восьме число І
от ми перший раз з вами зібрали Верховна
Рада друзі оце порядок денний оце
порядок денний покажіть мені питання
військових покажіть мені одне питання
про
військових ще раз
одне набу важливо сап
важливо все важливо суди
важливо де військо де с де збройні сили
де Нацгвардія де прикордонники Де
покажіть мені де ці питання на початку
цього засідання знов сказали від 6
грудня в нас День збройних сил Слава
Україні Героям слава Та може би Тоді
хоча б до Дня збройних сил перше
засідання після дня збройних сил перше
засідання в грудні одне питання про ЗСУ
мож було сюди поставити
одне наприклад про
демобілізацію демобілізацію після 18
місяців служби Подивіться виходять люди
по всій країні вже мами дружини доньки
сестри і говорять наші чоловіки не
ховалися наші сини пішли
добровільно вони врятували країну тоді
вони рятують її зараз Але чому ви не
даєте навіть відповіді на просте питання
А коли вони повернуться
додому Чому навіть у ув'язненого Господи
прости він знає свій термін
ув'язнення а військовий не знає скільки
йому
служити Ну це ж нечесно і несправедливо
до цих людей Ну вони ж заслужили на те
щоб хоча би розуміти скільки скільки
часу
Чому війна в нас вийшла справою одних
тих самих людей а для інших Це якась
інша історія вони на інших
фронтах Чому ну це ж неправильно Це
нечесно коли щось таке нечесне
відбувається воно нищить собою все
довіру в суспільстві довіру людей до
влади до країни Ну бо вони не знають
відповіді на це питання і це і це
ганебно що вони не знають відповіді на
це питання Верховній Раді України з
березня лежить мій законопроект з
березня
місяця який говорить просту річ дати
право тим хто були мобілізовані
звільнитися після 18 місяців служби
право Ті хто хочуть служити честь Хвала
подяка ті хто мають на це сили подяка ті
хто виснажилися ті хто втомилися мають
отримати право повернутися додому до
своїх родин і це питання нагальне я
звертаюсь до голови Верховної Ради Я
прошу вас Комітет з нацбезпеки оборони
восьмий місяць не розглядає цей
законопроект Ну чому Ну чим вони так
зайняті восьмий я звертався
безпосередньо до керівника я писав листи
Нічого не відбувається Ну можна
розглянути це питання цей законопроект
пішли якісь розмови зараз А давайте
нарешті хоч почали говорити останнім
часом але звучить якась історія
божевільна А давайте замість
демобілізації тим хто відслужив там 18
місяців дамо з них 12 на нуле дамо
місяці
відпустки А якщо 11 місяців на нулі а не
треба давати відпустку А 10 А
девть ну це Божевільні ідеї причому тут
відпустка замініть цих людей замінить їх
Вони мають на це
право і це очевидна абсолютна річ
Конституція каже захист держави
обов'язок кожно а не тільки цих пойменно
людей цього мільйона який сьогодні там
трішки
менше От так так не має бути і тому оцей
законопроект має бути ті хто говорять це
знищить боєздатність війська
брехня
брехня Я перепадав цей законопроект ще
оди будь ласка вісім тому що тоді коли я
його подавав в березні якщо б прийняли
то було шість місяців замінити зараз
враховуючи Що До сих пір не прийняли Да
не має бути так Що прийняли законопроект
і одразу там Десятки тисяч людей пішли з
війська Ми не можемо обвалити
боєздатність тому там простий запобіжник
я вставив що людина подає заяву рапорт
на звільнення і далі в ЗСУ є три місяці
людину відпустити тобто ЗСУ знає тут іде
гранатометник тут іде водій будь ласка
готуйте заміну і міняйте і міняйте людей
і так законопроект номер
один демобілізація і він має бути оцьому
порядку денному а не оце
все законоп я ще раз я за всі ці закони
Я за те що нам треба рухатись в Європу
за те в мене До речі одне питання Чому
ми так затягнули цими законами що зараз
терміново давайте доручимо спіке швидко
підписати ми знали всі ці умови з літа
минулого року чим Ми займалися чому ми
стільки часу не могли виконати ці умови
чому ми дочекалися Я хотів би подивитися
Минулого року коли росіяни бігли від нас
в Харківській області в Херсоні як Орбан
би щось с казав про Україну да всі були
готові на все тоді для України а ми тут
собі щось
телились не могли прийняти ці закони
дотягнули до останнього моменту за
тиждень до засідання Європейської ради
терміново приймаємо це до речі про наше
планування і про організацію роботи а до
чим завгодно до того займалися
куалолумпурськими якимись деклараціями
лобізмом якимось безкінечним а
євроінтеграцією зайнялись тільки коли
вже петух клюнув в одне місце Дай Боже
щоб все було добре І ще раз я за ці
закони
але все одно крім цих законів і так
перший закон демобілізація
закон номер два для збройних сил України
Про які ви казали 6 грудня Героям
слава Та вони би подякували всім нам
якщо б ми з вами прийняли один простий
закон про
ротацію про
ротацію чому сьогодні є підрозділи які
на нуле 21 місяць А є ті які більше ті
які були на Донбасі і кого війна вірніше
повномасштабне вторгнення заскочили там
вони вже більше двох років на нулі Ну
вони живі Люди ну людина не може
витримати
це Чому навіть всередині війська воює
Одні ті самі де ротація чому її немає та
Якщо це не в змозі зробити наше
військове керівництво Міністерство
оборони Ну давайте тоді робити ми я
подав Верховну Раду простий зрозумілий
законопроект три місяці на нулі далі
зобов'язані ротувати під підрозділ хоча
б на один місяць дати людям передихнути
відновитися
хоча б на один ну просте правило три
місяці був на нулі підрозділ дайте хоча
б один місяць хоча би передишки бажано
стільки скільки були на нулі три місяці
були значить три місяці Ну хоча б один Я
розумію що складно розумію що ворог
наступає все розумію але не можна Ну ми
зробили систему ну повністю абсурдну
систему в які воюють Одні ті самі А на
нуле серед них ще і ще Одні ті самі Ну
так не може бути мають бути ротації має
бути заміна і так законопроект номер
один демобілізація законопроект номер
два -
ротація простий і треба
робити законопроект номер
три Ну ми будемо ми повернемось обличчям
до наших військових 10 квітня цього року
квітня
віі місяців тому в цій сесійній залі був
проголосований закон про повернення
трицятки
всім з тих пір він висить заблокований
постановою
цабаля багато хто з людей вже думає
навіть що це не прізвище А що це якесь
слово щось інше
означає Ну так не може бути 8і
місяців ві
місяців Ну і просто висить цей ну його
можна давно вже розблокувати підписати і
і платити людям знову почалася проблема
з виплатами і доплатами знову водіям ні
логістиці ні в госпіталях ви не там
стоїте артилеристи ви не звідти
вистрілили ППО ви не там ловили того
шахеда і знов все це почалось ну скільки
це буде тривати ну проста і зрозуміла
система була і президент пообіцяв він
сказав до кінця війни буде тридцятка
війна не закінчилась тридцятка
закінчилась припиніть прикриватися як
фіговим лістком цією постановою бо під
нею негарне негарне срам під нею те що
ми просто не виконуємо Конституцію
плюємо на регламент Верховної Ради і
придумали собі історію що є в нас така
постанова якою ми
прикриємося ганебно це треба повертати
людям ці гроші До сих пір війську є люди
яких виводять поза штат які отримують
сьогодні 700 800 грвень на місяць мені
соромно про це казати мені соромно мені
пишуть ці люди безкінечно мені соромно Я
не знаю як їм дивитись в очі Я не знаю
як дивитись цим людям в очі які віддали
своє здоров'я за державу а сьогодні
отримують 700-800 грн на місяць і їх не
відпускають з війська тому що першого
закону про демобілізацію
немає немає і їх не відпускають і гроші
їм не платять ну ну ну В нас же має бути
якась совість Ну якась мінімальна
совість Ну так не може бути ідемте далі
так закон номер один я Нагадую що це не
складно Все я вам кажу яким має бути
порядок денний За який всі військові нам
скажуть
Дякуємо Нарешті ви зробили свою роботу
ми ми робимо свою роботу рятуємо країну
Нарешті ви зробили свою роботу допомогли
нам демобілізація заміна раз ротація два
повернення тридцятки три наступне
питання
убд Ну ми з вами проголосували вже в
першому читанні коли ми будемо
голосувати остаточно щоб людина могла
отримати статус учасника бойових дій без
всіх цих знущань без всіх цих понавірянь
чекань якихось Запитів листів які
безкінечно безкінечно
тягнуться і люди роками не можуть
отримати статус БД і це вже навіть вже
не про Гроші про елементарну повагу
елементарну да винесіть же ви
врешті-решт цей закон на голосування
перше читання проголосовано голосуємо
друге читання Все поставили крапку
скільки можна про це просити скільки
треба про це говорити
скільки далі
наступна важлива тема надзвичайно
важлива тема це тема наших
полонених тема інвалідів тема
демобілізації окремих груп не по
термінам служби А якщо ти попав в певний
в певну групу в нас є військові які були
в полоні і ми з вами розуміємо які не
самі туди здалися яких взяли в полон І
ми з вами розуміємо наскільки це
колосальний виклик пройти і пережити цей
полон ми знаємо з вами вчора
уповноважений з питань прав людини
Верховної Ради сказав найбільший
найстрашніший випадок під час полону
військовослужбовець втратив 70 кг ваги
70 ну це і це був військовослужбо ну це
Ми ро ну ну це страшно що з цими людьми
зробили вони повернулись ми їх Слава
Богу обміняли кого змогли окрема тема
обмінів люди постійно пишуть розумію Що
росіяни не хочуть обмінювати Я розумію
що в них навіть більше наших полонених
ніж нас їхніх але все одно тут треба
робити все що можемо але це не від нас
залежить але що залежить від нас тим
кого обміняли відпустити їх да серед тих
хто були в полоні є ті які готові
служити далі подяка але іншим треба дати
право звільнитися це чесно інваліди
першої другої групи у війську і третьої
групи теж інваліди які є у війську перша
друга третя група Ну треба дати їм право
звільнитися ну В нас сьогодні з вами в
законі сказано закон говорить якщо в
тебе теща інвалід першої другої групи
або третьої якщо є довідка що вона
потребує постійного догляду то ти можеш
звільнитися А якщо ти сам інвалід першої
другої третьої групи
то дулю Ну я це ідіотизм ну абсурд
але це наш закон коли ми це будемо
виправляти коли ми відпустимо цих людей
нащо тримати війську
силоміть інвалідів першої другої третьої
групи да можливо є офіцер інвалід другої
групи він в штабі Він хоче служити Дай
Боже хай служить але ті хто війську
безпосередньо ті хто не можуть служити
інваліди першої другої третьої групи та
ми можемо їх врешті-решт
відпустити в Раді є законопроекти про це
давно Ну давайте їх проголосуємо нарешті
почали про це говорити після півроку як
ми б'ємо тут усі дзвони але говорити
мало Треба голосувати і оце би нам
сказали Дякую далі строковики
це взагалі вже це слово стало синонімом
якогось я вже це слово Мені здається що
я знаю там більшість строковиків
особисто в цій державі тому що цін
Вибачте це нещасні люди які просто
потрапили як в рабство якесь четвертий
рік з лютого були на зарплаті 400 грн
Слава Богу ми прийняли цей закон якого я
виступав просив ви підтримали ми разом
прийняли хоча б вони отримали 6,000 грн
цієї доплати хоч ті нещасні 6,000 грн бо
вони взагалі 400 отримували по закону
моєму вони отримали 30 днів відпустки бо
в них був нуль днів відпустки хоч щось
але давайте вже їх відпустимо додому ну
це чесно люди служать вже четвертий рік
четвертий нарешті два тижня тому на
ставки Верховного головнокомандувача
було обговорено Це питання вийшов
Секретар
нацбез Ради нацбезпеки оборони Данілов і
сказав президент почув звернувся
військові підтримали будемо відпускати
строковиків всі Ура нарешті
і
і ну третій тиждень іде ну ви ж сказали
будете відпускати так відпустіть вже
нарешті нуже Ви знущаєтесь Ну вже
сказали то
зробіть ну сказано вже навіть Та
відпустіть вже їх і відпустіть їх не так
щоб їх завтра забрали отдайте людям
відстрочку після цього хоч щоб вони
реально повернулись додому до своїх
родин щоб вони Хоч якийсь час там точно
змоли ли провести ну скільки це можна
чекати і Скільки треба чекати всі закони
які я говорю покажіть мені хто буде
проти них в цій Верховній Раді покажіть
мені ладно про тридцятку потрібні гроші
з грошима погано Нам гроші зараз не
дають правда все одно при цьому
знаходяться гроші на серіали на дурню
якусь знаходяться на
телемарафони знаходяться
гроші а те що я сказав фротація не
потребує жодної копійки жодної
відпустити строковиків відпустити
інвалідів відпустити тих хто були в
полоні які прийняти закон про термін
служби про заміну військовослужбовців Це
не потребує грошей це потребує просто
роботи і поваги до військових
поваги прийняти нами З вами закон про
списання майна два місяці наму колега
Роман Костенко був першим автором я мав
честь бути
співавтором ми з вамиі всі
проголосували і він просто ігнорується
Він просто не підписується третій місяць
президентом і наші військові щоби
списати якусь там казку щоби списати той
Дрон який їм там Дай Боже якщо
подарували волонтери бо держава Ніяк не
може забезпечити мають Отакі стоси
паперів Отакі заповнити сидять люди які
тільки тим займаються в нас люди кажуть
У нас у па тільки не героїчна Українська
повстанська армія А бюрократична
українська паперова армія та якщо це
прийняте Та ми звільнимо людей та може
когось можна звільнити зі служби А
когось можна зняти щоб людина не сиділа
з цими паперами а йшла безпосередньо
воювала може нам взагалі потрібно менше
людей у війську але таких які реально
воюють а не заповнюють
папери в нас вже все
перекручено як яка там величезна армія
скільки воює скільки на першій другій
лінії Ну так не може бути неправильно
два місяці президента на підписі
законопроект він просто не підписує Вже
третій місяць іде що ми чекаємо що ми
чекаємо це я перелічив питання тільки по
військових я там є ще питання опікунів
теж там відпустити Я кожну категорію
зараз не назву але там багато питань які
нам треба раз і прийняти ці
рішення але це не робиться і знов
порядок денний і знову в порядку денному
жодного питання про військових Скажіть
будь ласка скільки це буде тривати ну це
же ми самі себе пиляємо той сук на якому
сидимо ми знищуємо
державу друзі я це все що я зараз говорю
я да депутатів зараз в залі стало
суттєво менше бо всіх одразу виявились
справи Як вониі знались що буде Значить
великий виступ то порозходилась частина
потім
повернеться розумію що дуже важливе
обговорення йде і в тому числі в
Президії там враховуючи Персональний
склад можливо обговорюється якась
константа там це це цілком можливо Друзі
Ну от така історія розумієте Як тільки
питання військових не цікаво розійшлись
не чуємо не займаємось а далі
обговорюємо свої справи І все добре і
якби і всі Ну і все Ну просто хочу да от
Подивіться поки я далі виступаю
Подивіться хочу щоб подивились на
президію я звертаюсь до нас до всіх якщо
ми зараз з вами це не зрозуміємо на кого
ми маємо з вами працювати реально а не
на словах в нас будуть величезні
проблеми нас врятує з вами друзі не
знаєте кажуть Ми час в от США саме
головне три букви
США ні інші кажуть ЄС дві букви ЄС чи
три букви МВФ МВФ ні наші три букви які
нас врятують це ЗСУ це нгу це
ДПСУ от це ну і далі ссо тро і так далі
от ті літери які ми на які ми маємо
працювати дивіться бачите Ну там вже і
константа в Президії все тут не до нас з
нашими
розмовами але я не можу не сказати зараз
декілька теж важливих речей бо люди
пишуть Якщо ви хочете щоби озвучено було
ваше
питання То пишіть я спробую його підняти
ще одне питання дитячі
виплати на сайті президента я
зареєстрував петицію яка передбачає яка
звертається до президента щонайменше
вдвічі вдвічі збільшити виплати дитячі
Ну бо 860 грн це ніщо тобто перші наші
питання які ми маємо зробити це військо
для війська друге питання щоб в нас це
військо було в майбутньому Щоб була та
мама яка народить того воїна який буде
нас захищати цю неньку Україну через 18
20 30 років Хто це буде коли ми цій мамі
сьогодні даємо 860 грн на місяць що вона
з ними може
зробити Ну давайте ми це зробимо Це наш
з вами прямий
обов'язок питання пенсій інвалідам
питання виплати інвалідам ну це все
колосальні питання які ми з вами не
вирішуємо До речі питання важливе
про збройні сили коли я казав це
питання пільгового розмитнення на
автівки для наших воїнів бо багато хто з
них буде потребувати це бо не дай Бог
будуть з інвалідністю їм треба це буде
багато хто сьогодні намагається купити
щоб завести щоб там на пдке працювати
так Давайте дамо їм таку можливість і це
є в Верховній Раді все що я перелічив
всі ці закони в Верховній Раді України є
А чого нема А нема бажання займатися
роботою нема бажання
займатися своїми справжнім тим чим ми
маємо зайнятися і це є величезна друзі
чезна проблема Я хочу вам сказати що ці
проблеми
розуміють ці проблеми краще ніж ми з
вами Мені здається розуміють за кордоном
я тільки що повернувся з за кордону де в
тому числі як багато хто зараз там були
в Сполучених Штатах Америки переконували
підтримка України Гроші все все все але
там ставлять питання А що в вас
домобілізації А чого одні і ті самі на
фронті А чому дружини мають виходити на
вулиці щоб хтось почув про їхніх
чоловіків А цього абсолютно немає просто
цього немає тобто в США краще розуміють
проблематику ніж тут в Верховній Раді
України Ну це ж божевілля так же не має
бути А на жаль в нас продовжується все
те саме Я ще раз звертаю вашу увагу я
перелічив конкретні
пункти Як має виглядати правильне
засіданняр Ради України Я пропоную
зробити засідання Верховної Ради
присвячене тільки цим пунктам тільки ці
закони ніякого лобізму ніяких декларацій
ніяких заяв чергових нікому не
потрібних заміна демобілізація раз
ратація- два грошові виплати три
повернення тридцятки в тому числі три
звільнення дати право на звільнення тим
хто пройшов полон інвалідам обмежено
придатним
розмитнення вирішити демобілізація
строковиків зібратися і за годину бо тут
не буде навіть дискусій тут не буде
дебатів тут все всім зрозуміло прийняти
ці рішення Я вимагаю
цього якщо ви думаєте що ця тема сама
собо розсмокчиться якщо ви думаєте що
там Ну по-перше що я колись закрию рота
я рота не
закрию як би там до мене не приходили в
помешкання наші сбушники встановлювати
прослуховуючу апаратуру чим займаються є
СБУ Герої які сьогодні як ми бачимо
зрадниками займаються Привет
ківі є герої яким ми маємо подякувати А
є працівники СБУ які займаються з тим
щоб закрити рота представникам тим
депутатам політикам які підіймають
питання незручні Та хай Встановіть мені
всю апаратуру хоча б вішайте мене як
ялинку Мені байдуже це все я буду далі
говорити якщо ви сподіваєтесь що це
закриється тема не закриється і все одно
доведеться вам як довелося відпуски
приймати довелося не змогли обійти це
довелося хоч щось дати строкови хоч щось
курсантам хоч щось правда через одне
місце інструкторам бо там зробили
знущання тися паперів треба Але все одно
довелося довелося хоч якоїсь частині
виведених поза штат ті хто не непридатні
обмежено придатні по захисту батьківщини
довелося доведеться і демобілізацією і
заміною
займатися доведеться і строковиків
відпускати доведеться але чим раніше ми
це зробимо тим скоріше ці люди вони
скажуть да нас бачать нас чують це є
держава яка нас поважає це є держава за
яку не соромно воювати а не це є держава
яка витирає у нас ноги яки плювати
хотіла на нас на наше життя і просто
використовує нас як м'ясо оце страшні
слова
страшні просто страшні слова а їх я чую
кожен день бо на відміну Я так розумію
від вас які мені тут радили щоб дешевші
памперси купляли люди Я розумію цю
проблематику Я спілкуюсь з цими людьми
кожен день кожен день і вони стукаються
Вони шукають Вони шукають Вони шукають
хто їх почує тому що їх на жаль ніхто не
хоче чути і зараз і зараз це все
продовжується між собойчик в Президії
продовжується в Президії все
добре напевно ліси обговорюють чи
кол-центри чи константичи ще щось А ми
тим часом друзі маємо колосальну
проблему я завершую найбільший виклик
нашої
держави да да от подивіться що чим за
трибуну наша президія все о спікер почав
слухати Дякую нарешті я вас завжди чую
Дякую вам па навіть якщо ви не бачите і
не чуєте Я вас завжди
чую сподіваю це така штучка є навушни не
завжди це цікаво але я завжди чую
сподіваюся що це не після того як до
мене зайшли якоби чиніть інтернет
ззбушники повесить мікрофон що ви тепер
мене завжди чуєте але цей я хочу сказати
вам одне найбільша найбільша проблема
держави яка є це не те що в нас проблеми
в США це не те що в нас проблеми в
Євросоюзі це навіть не корупція
це да божевільний наш сусід агресор і це
той Бардак бардак відсутність системного
мислення яке є на чолі держави Оце є
найбільша проблема бо це нищить все і це
підриває довіру бо найбільш наш Актив
Актив України сьогодні найбільший це не
чорноземи це не газ це не нафта
це збройні сили України Це сили оборони
і цей Актив нас витягне і в НАТО Я вірю
і в ЄС бо їм вони потрібні і мені
здається що вони їм трібні більше ніж
українським політикам і це ганьба ЗСУ
демобілізація заміна ротація строковики
Оце має бути наше гасло слава